hello there I'm John Oliver
host of HBO's this week right now or
whatever the it's called uh we are
off this week but we wanted to quickly
address one absolutely huge story
naturalists are predicting a big summer
for cicadas in the Northeast big noisy
and numerous cicadas are set to emerge
again from their unusually long
reproductive cycle the ones coming out
of the ground this summer were conceived
in 1999 yes the cicadas are coming and
this latest batch have been hidden from
the world since 1999 and if they're
anything like humans conceived in 1999
I'm guessing all the girl cicadas are
named Madison Andy boy cicadas named
Tyler
sadly they won't have much time among us
they'll live for two to six weeks mate
and then die and so and so that they
don't wait that's an odd thing to would
but so so they don't waste too much time
catching up on what they missed I just
want to take a few minutes now to get
them up to speed on what has happened in
the last 17 years um so yeah welcome to
the new millennium welcome to the new
millennium cicadas a lot fewer people
are calling it the millennium than we
thought they would in 1999 um first let
me catch you up on politics we voted in
a second President Bush by a narrow
margin and rejected a third president
bush pilot enormous margin as for
technology we've made a lot of strides
since 1999 for example the internet no
longer screams in agony as you dial into
it from your phone line in fact you
might well be watching this on YouTube
which is a video distribution platform
where teenagers become famous for
playing video games and opening boxes
in sports news the Red Sox finally won a
World Series making their fans somehow
even more insufferable and at Michael
Jordan while still possibly the greatest
basketball player ever it's now someone
that we mostly make fun of because he
cried one time in terms of pop culture
and brace yourself because there are
some big surprises here dr. Dre is now a
multi-millionaire electronics mogul this
guy won a Grammy for best rap song the
curly haired guy from NSYNC is one of
the biggest entertainers in the world
and the lead singer of R&B group
Destiny's Child is essentially our queen
now on your knees secateurs on your
knees before the Queen oh and some
things that were very popular in 1999
have become a lot scarce sir such as
carbohydrates and Cosby shel reruns and
and finally and finally and amazingly we
all just stopped playing for music and
porn and I think we've gotten away with
it so frankly that that should be in
secateurs you're pretty much all caught
up enjoy the world while you have the
chance because to be honest depending on
how things go in November this planet
might not be around in another 17 years
and I do not have time to explain that
to you thanks so much for watching we
will be back next week goodbye